this might be the most insane clip we've
ever shown on this show you think this
might be it this might be it this might
be it this might maybe I'm going to
retire right after we show you this
thing what you were about to see and of
course it is from MSNBC is so patently
stupid ridiculous bananas give me
another adjective
horse
that you are going
to strap yourself in here you go MSNBC
here's what's going on in Florida
Aisha this is I have talked for seven
years about the asymmetry of covering
trumpism in America something so
audacious and so unimaginable that the
normal ways of rapidly responding are
inadequate this seems to address that
asymmetry and
um and say I I got this what do you
think
I think it was extremely clever um and I
really appreciate the naacp's guidance
uh on this issue you know I just took my
family to spring break in Florida
recently and I think about all of the
folks who traveled there for Sun and joy
and peace and restoration and to be
reminded that actually this is getting
to the point where Florida is about to
be a terrorist state to to many of us
here in America certainly as a lesbian
as a black woman I don't want to have
anything to do with the place
um and I think about all the other
people who don't want to travel there
either and so I think it was very clever
on behalf of the NAACP I thank them for
issuing this broad uh guidance and you
know really what it does is it turns a
remarkable uh I think lens on the United
States and highlights how bigotry and
bias and ignorance do as much harm uh as
we accuse other countries of doing to
people that they suppress
okay do you realize that that black
lesbian
just weeks ago took her family which I
assume includes her lesbian wife and
children to Florida for vacation where
they enjoyed Sun joy peace and
restoration then only because the NAACP
put out this statement she has now
realized that only weeks ago she was in
a terrorist state
it's so profoundly stupid it's so
profoundly dishonest that host Nicole
Wallace is an abject embarrassment I was
going to really go off on her on Twitter
yesterday but she doesn't have a Twitter
because she knows she's an abject
embarrassment completely ridiculous if
you ask that woman I think her name's
Aisha Mills if you ask her well did
anything happen to you on your lesbian
family vacation did anything negative
happen to you in Florida the answer
obviously is no
[Music]
no